wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
nico selber was machst du denn hier ein
bankkonto heißt es du bleibst hier in
deutschland ja cool und was wir zu
machen studieren ja eigentlich ich habe
schon in spanien zwei semester jura
studiert
ich möchte nicht mehr studieren ich
möchte mit den händen arbeiten einen
beruf lernen
du möchtest eine ausbildung machen ja
ich denke schon
da muss jetzt aber schnell deutsch
lernen ich dir gleich zum sprachkurs
kommst du mit ja
zuerst muss ich haben bankautomaten noch
geld abheben bank spricht schon sehr gut
ich bin ja schon anja hier warst du kurz
[Musik]
es tut mir leid
das ist schon passiert ich habe zuerst
karte in den automaten gesteckt dann
habe ich auf geldabheben gedrückt danach
kam eine fehlermeldung
ich konnte meine pin noch gar nicht
eingeben und die karte kam nicht mehr
heraus einer der bankangestellten musste
mir helfen aber es hat geklappt
wir kennen gehen
[Musik]